- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape,
bipedal, naked, large brain, long the
master of fire, tools and language but
still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable yet filled
with optimism. We grow up slowly. We hand
down knowledge. We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past. Carta brings
together experts from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are and
how we got here. An exploration made
possible by the generosity
of humans like you.
♪ [music] ♪
- Thank you, and thank you very
much for the invitation to join you today.
As speakers of English when we hear
constructions like, "Get 'em, bring 'em,
take 'em," we analyze those as a verb and
a pronoun. Get them or get him, bring them
or bring him. This analysis is supported
by the fact that we read and write. We
rarely see the informal forms written it's
usually the formal forms and through
schooling which generally tell us to use
the formal forms and to leave the others
alone but we also know when it's
appropriate to use which style in which
context. We're now going to move to a
different context where speakers heard
those constructions but analyze them
differently. When Australia was colonized,
there were about 250 languages spoken by
indigenous people. The speakers of the
Australian languages and the English
speakers had to learn to communicate with
each other very quickly. Usually the
English speakers didn't learn much of the
Australian languages. The earnest was on
the indigenous people to learn as much
English as they
could to get by with.
So let's imagine that the English speakers
we're using the informal constructions a
lot when they were speaking. "Take 'em
over there, bring 'em back," constructions
like that that we use all the time without
thinking about it. The speakers of the
Australian languages who hadn't yet
learned English identified a pattern in
what they were hearing. When they heard
verbs like get, bring, take they
frequently heard something like, "'-im"
occurring after the verb but they didn't
hear that when the verb was something like
walk which doesn't have a direct object.
So they came to analyze the "'-im" that we
would think of as a pronoun as being a
grammatical element that attaches to a
transitive verb. It's a verb with an
object but not to verbs
like walk and run.
They didn't have literacy or schooling to
influence their analysis. They just made
this analysis from identifying patterns in
the language being spoken to them and what
they heard around them. So the transitive
"-im," or the transitive marker is a new
structure that came in to that system that
was not the same as a structure that was
already in English and it was not in the
Australian languages either but we can
see where it came from but the Australian
languages did influence that structure in
abstract ways. The form of  "-im" is
clearly from English but there are other
influences from the Australian languages.
I've just listed a few of them here. One
is for example that in those languages
when you have a transitive verb
construction it's a different
construction from an intransitive verb. So
those speakers learned to pay attention to
the transitivity of the verb in every
clause because that was required by their
grammar. So it made sense to them based on
the first languages to have a different
construction for a transitive
versus an intransitive verb.
In addition, there were rules for words
and the sound systems within the language
that the Australian verbs didn't suit very
well and the new analysis suited them
better. So for example words in
Australian languages are often at least
two syllables long. If you have a short
verb, adding the transitive marker made it
longer and conformed more to the rules of
the first languages. So normally words in
Australian languages in that area didn't
usually end with a cluster of consonants
at the end of the word. So again, adding
that marker made the word shape conform
more to the type of verb that speakers of
those languages were used to.
The "-im" structure is a good example of
some characteristics of a pidgin. The word
forms come mostly from the language that
was spoken by the socially dominant group
which we call the lexifier language but a
lot of the structure and word meanings
come from the other multiple languages
that were being spoken by the creators. In
addition, reanalysis take place such as
what we've just seen through pattern
finding processes and second language
learning processes. A pidgin is a means of
inter-group communication.
You use it to speak to people who's
language you don't know and all of those
speakers were still using their own first
languages when they spoke to people within
their same group. The pidgin spread
throughout Australia as English speakers
spread throughout Autralia and in each
place there were Australian languages and
those speakers were contributing features
to the new system. Indigenous people where
brought together in groups and needed to
interact with speakers of many other
languages with whom traditionally they
wouldn't have interacted much or at all.
So they all needed a way to speak to each
other and this system was a good system
to build on in order to do that.
As speakers needed to talk about more and
more topics with each other more and more
elements were added from English and also
from the Australian languages. Varieties
of northern territory Kriol were derived
from interactions of this kind.
Here's an example.
- [recording] Det mami-wan en
det tu pikanini bin trai stop-im im bat
det debil-debil bin
gwei garra det tu dog.
- And you can see there the
transitive marker on the verb, which came
in via the pidgin. There's
another interesting element there
which is, "bin" meaning past tense. Again,
the form is from English have been, had
been but there's another reanalysis there
so it just means simple past tense. It's
not part of the have been or had been
construction. Reasearch
suggests that there's more than one
developmental path for a Kriol language
but this has won a tested path. Again, the
word forms come mostly from the socially
dominant language English but much of the
structure and the word meanings come from
the other input languages. In this case,
there was an earlier pidgin that fed in to
the Kriol. Reanalysis took place through
pattern finding and second language
learning processes and the system
expanded and developed. There was a prior
pidgin that was used
for inter-group communication.
A Kriol is the first language of its
speakers and is a full language. This
variety of Kriol continued to develop and
stabilize probably up until about the
1940s and '50s and it
currently has several varieties.
We'll turn now to another kind of contact
language in another setting in Australia.
This is in a small Warlpiri community in
the northern territory. In this community,
speakers over about the age of 35 mostly
speak Warlpiri their traditional
language but they also code switch into
varieties of English and Kriol. Code
switching is switching between languages
in a single conversation and by Aboriginal
English there I mean English with elements
of the indigenous languages and elements
of Kriol in it. Younger speakers, younger
adults and children speak in a new way
which systematically combines elements
from those sources in which we call Light
Warlpiri. Children learn to speak this
language from when they first begin to
talk now. As they grow older, they also
produce Walpiri and they code switch into
the English based varieties. The Children
now learn Light Warlpiri and Walpiri from
birth. We'll look at a little background
structure of the contributing languages
before we look at the
structure of Light Warlpiri.
- [recording] Nyina-ja-lku-lpa-lu
warlu-ngka jarntu-kurlu palka-kurlu.
- [recording] Puta wajili-pu-ngu
kurdu-ngku-ju jarntu-ju ngula ka-ngu
kuuku-ngku.
- As you can see there,
Warlpiri is a suffixing
language. A lot of the
grammatical functions are indicated
through suffixes on words. We can also see
here the difference between the transitive
and intransitive construction that I
mentioned earlier that the pidgin creators
paid attention to. The word there for
for child who's doing the chasing,
and the monster who's doing the taking
have a suffix on them that doesn't occur
on nouns when there's an intransitive verb
like walk. So it's in that way that these
constructions are quite different and in
contrast varieties of English and Kriol
indicate grammatical functions mostly
through separate words and
with fairly fixed word order.
So how do this languages combine in this
new system, light Warlpiri?
- [recording] Ngalipa jalangwi-m kam
ka-kurl nyampu-kurra ngurra-kurra.
- [recording] Junga mayi
nyuntu yu-m go karnta-kurl?
- [recording] Botul-ing i-m
panturn-um taya.
- You might
notice that their
English verbs there come and go. Much of
the verb system of Light Warlpiri is from
Aboriginal English and Kriol verb
structure but not entirely.
If you look at example three, there's
actually a Warlpiri verb stem but it has
the Kriol transitive marker on it. So the
over all structure is derived from those
languages. You can see there the Warlpiri
suffixing. So we have the verbal structure
mostly from Aboriginal English and Kriol
but we have all of the noun structure
retained from Warlpiri but in the verbal
structure there are also innovations
which indicated in green, the "wi-m" and
the "yu-m" and they're what we most
interested in today. This pattern of
verbal structure from one source and noun
structure from another source is fairly
unusual in the world's languages. The
differences between Warlpiri and Light
Warlpiri are in the verb and auxiliary
structure, which have these clearly
different forms but the underlying
abstract structure is more complicated. So
the "wi-m" and "yu-m" constructions which
are the innovations are part of an overall
system much of which already existed
in Kriol and Aboriginal English. You can
see there that for each word there's a
pronoun element like we, you, a-rra which
is from I and then there's another element
which mostly means time. So where did this
wi-m and yu-m construction come from. We
know that it's not something that comes
from English. Well, it seems that the -im
came from English I'm like the form but
there's also an -im in the aboriginal
English in Kriol pronouns i-m and de-m.
Through this process of creating the
structure they were reanalyzed so that
instead of being a pronoun i-m or de-m
there were a new structure where they were
divided into two parts.
Aboriginal English and Kriol has this past
marker "bin" and that rarely occurs in
Light Warlpiri. So instead of using that
what has happened is that the speakers
have taken the past meaning from bin and
overlaid it on the -m element from English
and aboriginal English and Kriol such that
they have this new structure where the -m
is a separate morphing with it's own
meaning that means present or past or
non-future and then that is regularized
across the system and you have a new
paradigm.
Another example.
- [recording]"Ngaju-ng na
a-rra ged-im ma kard. "
- [recording] "Yu-m ged-im
nyurru first waya ngaju-janga. "
- There were some kids playing a card
game for me and using that structure
there. So what are the influences on the
new structure? Again, we see that the word
shape or form comes from the varieties
of English or Kriol but the structure and
the meaning comes from multiple sources.
In Warlpiri, the auxiliary has a structure
where there's a time element which is the
"ka-" there meaning present and a pronoun
element  and you can see that all through
the system these are affixes. They're not
separate words. So I think that this
underlying structure of wanting a time
element and a pronoun element affixed
together was part of the influence that
fed into the new system. In Warlpiri, the
verb and the auxiliary forms combine in
different kinds of contructions to give
the same kinds of semantic readings as we
find in Light Warlpiri.
So in the final column those three
meanings of non-future, future and
desiderative or one, two are exactly the
categories that we find in Light Walpiri
but they're not structural categories in
Warlpiri they're semantic categories and
again they've been overlaid onto the
forms in Light Warlpiri. So how did the
whole language come to be? It was through
a two-step process when the adult groups
who are now about 35 years old with
children I think that other adults spoke
to them in what is known as a baby talk
register and in that register they code
switched a lot and they code switched in a
particular pattern. So it would be
something like this where there would be a
Walpiri sentence but they would insert
a Kriol pronoun and verb into that
sentence and that is the pattern that
the children then conventionalized by
analyzing it as a single system. At the
same time, they added the innovations that
we've just been talking about. That
group of children who I think did this
maybe when they were three, four or five
certainly before they were teenagers. They
then grew up had children of their own and
so now those children learned that
language as one of their first languages
along with Warlpiri and it's their
primary language. So the path to this
language is a little different. It wasn't
created for inter-group communication. It
was created within one group of people in
one community and it's only spoken within
that group of people in that community.
The speakers were multilingual there was a
lot of code switching. It was directed to
children, very young children in a
particular pattern. They then
conventionalized it and reanalyzed some of
the input they were hearing and then
regularized their analysis
to create new paradigms.
From English and Kriol we get words and a
lot of verb structure. From Warlpiri we
get words, the noun structure and also
abstract verbal structure and this new
system is the first language of the
current generations. So what we've been
able to see almost in real time is a new
language developed and an innovative
structure in that language through a
two-step process. Adults had fairly
systematic code switching in the speech
that they were directing to children and
then the children had a very creative role
in conventionalizing that input and adding
the innovations. The overall structure is
unusual because it combines the noun
structure from one type of language with
the verb structure for another and there
are these innovations which are
interesting in that we can see exactly
where they've come from. We can see
exactly the reanalysis that have taken
place and we can see that at the end of
that reanalysis there is a new
construction.
Thank you.